just like old times get the space land
map in Call of Duty infinite warfare
zombie mode takes you to an 80s theme
park styled as a future Kitsch
battleground given the time setting
there's no better ambassador than David
Hasselhoff to join you as a temporary
NPC you'll spot him as a DJ spinning 80s
hits and thankfully he holds back on
belting out his own songs that kind of
made him popular in Germany he's way
more helpful as a laser wielding squad
mate than working behind a turntables
which is why you should call him from
the neon heavens power up the theme park
and leave the initial area as you
normally would we recommend replacing
the Glock as soon as possible and having
both the m14 powered range shots and
banshee for crowd control then run down
the main path until you see a candy
cluster concession stand
grab the robot head then go back down
the path to where the gift shops are and
look for the robot body at the centre of
the path placing the robot head on the
body will trigger the modes challenges
you will have to complete enough
challenges to fill up the circle on the
upper left corner of the screen this
playlist of challenges does not unfold
in any specific order so be prepared for
anything when pulling off the kills
while jumping challenge point diagonally
down while jumping save your explosives
for the multi kill challenges with the
melee challenge
soften the zombies with a couple rounds
before knocking them down it's safer
than being within arm's reach at all
times when you fill the circle run back
to the robot after you've activated it
it will launch into space give it a few
seconds to come back and voila the
Michael Knight version of the Hoff he's
a solid party member who will follow one
of your teammates for a few minutes as
he tried to survive a couple ways from
what we've seen so far he can't revive
you good luck your breakfast club will
need it for more on call of duty
infinite warfare keep it here on
GameSpot
groovy kids but I need more parts to
work with
you
you